hello again it's spring the sun is
shining some of the time everything is
growing lots of birds and bees and other
creatures are flowing around doing their
thing and it's time to get out in the
garden and this is I've been a little
bit stuck trying to finish my book
because I keep looking out the window
and thinking I should be out there doing
things outside so I thought given time
let's do this little video bell books I
would do a video about a couple of books
to do with gardening and they both come
out in the last month or so the first
one I'm going to share with you is
called edible paradise it's by a woman
called Vera I wish I could pronounce her
surname I could not do it justice I'm
sure we don't get very well trained in
foreign languages in England but there
there it is Vera I do apologize for not
knowing how to pronounce your surname
she's from the Netherlands and she's
been gardening for over 30 years and
this book is all about her experiences
around learning how to grow plenty of
food well what'd she say here herbs
flowers and veggies in any space and
it's very much focused on a permaculture
approach it's it's very much organic
it's no dig which is becoming people are
becoming a bit more aware of how to do
no date particularly Charles darlings
books and and she quotes him one of the
people that inspired her and his lovely
work it's full of color it's always easy
to skim these things from the back to
the front both of the books I'm going to
mention have a guide to the months of
the year and what you can do at
different months so if you're starting
now which is May as I'm doing this video
you can just go straight to May and see
okay what kind of things are we doing
what do we need to do in May and some of
us are perhaps more experienced
gardeners and
think of these two books this book
certainly pitched at perhaps somebody
has a bit more experience but it doesn't
assume that you know how to do things do
everything so it's it's a lovely book
regardless of whether you have a lot of
experience of not because there's
something in here for everybody and I
was certainly enjoying reading this book
she has quite a lot about polycultures
so polycultures are how we put plants
together in what we call in permaculture
guilds so a guild is a collection of
species but in this case we're talking
plants primarily which are placed
together deliberately in order to create
mutual benefit and beneficial
relationships so for a fruit tree we
might place around that fruit tree in
its proximity plants that may be
providing nitrogen fixation or
attracting pollinators or accumulating
particular minerals of values that
plants or attracting pest predators that
might prey on the plant and so on and we
put these deliberate collections of
species plants primarily together
because it could include birds a bird
could be a pest predator that might be
attracted to maybe eating the bugs in
the fallen fruit which stop that cycle
of those bugs impacting the fruit next
year and she starts off by looking at
what you can do in containers in the
garden back to this how do I show this
and put into the camera at the same time
but you can see it's full of beautiful
photographs both of these books full of
lots of lovely photographs her favorite
flowers to eat how you might put things
together so she looks at polycultures
from the perspective of different levels
we might cause of structural diversity
in this space so how she might do that
with a container for instance and
Hoegaarden her in her husband's garden
with the children
and what they do through the year and
slobby features of those other gardens
throughout the year the different things
she does different varieties of plants
that she recommends it's a really lovely
book she has a blog well I say a blog
yes there is a blog and the YouTube
channel which is I'm a bit more familiar
with which is in Dutch and there's an
English one an english-language one as
well which is really good and yes I just
highly recommend this book it's really
nice particularly the focus on how do
you put plants together in order to
create beneficial polycultures that's
really nice lots of lovely photographs
so she's been growing since she was 12
this chap Hugh Hugh Richards he's being
he's had a YouTube channel since he was
12 and has been gardening with his
parents in he was 3 so he's just turned
20 I believe and he's already written
his first book it's amazing and it was
very lucky to meet you he came when a
permaculture design course with us last
year and his book has come out
subsequent to this and he's an amazing
it's a young man most people eat young
by my standards these days and not only
has he written this book he's also got
this YouTube channel now which has had
over he's got over a hundred thousand
subscribers it's called Hughes nursery
well worth checking out and he's really
focused on helping people to learn how
to grow food for themselves and of
course as permaculturist s-- one of the
key things we can do in order to improve
and reduce our impact on the world is to
grow some of our own food and whose
mission really is about making that
really easy for people now he's but
there's lots of books about gardening
around so Hughes focus on the book the
idea for the book is how do you grow
lots of different vegetables in about 19
different vegetables in one place so
it's kind of
looking at a poly culture is it's kind
of not quite crop rotation but he takes
that into account we looks at how you
could create a three meter by 1.2 meter
or 10 foot by 4 foot bed and grow lots
of different vegetables and once we get
past the beginning part which just looks
at how to make compost and make your
raised bed pretty kind of simple stuff
he gets into whoops yeah the the plans
the year plans and so each of these
raised beds is divided into ten rows
along the bed and he takes you through
what to plant at each row throughout the
whole year and that's the basis of the
book so how to grow the different plants
or hints and tips that he has for that
and each each month has its own section
so we can may so each time you're
looking at what's in the bed what should
be in the bed he's telling you how to
grow things and what to raise when and
when you plant them out and someone who
so forth
and the whole book is the book is mostly
focused around all of that and then
towards the end once you got to the end
of your first year you then gives you
some ideas for future years so in
particular situations so cool climate
flaunting low rainfall planting a salad
bed and so on and this one is all about
if you don't have much time you want to
make it really easy and then they talks
a little bit about rotation and so on
but I'd say of course what's in this
book is not new but the way he's put it
together for me I've not seen that
before and I think it's a really nice
way of supporting people and this is
very much for people who are beginners
and even those of us who are not quite
so beginners who like to think about how
we might teach other people to do things
in such a small space because really
what he's demonstrating is how much food
you can grow in such a small space so
two great books for the spring to people
very much authors worth supporting check
out their channels and enjoy your summer
of gardening